- Erica is a clinical professor
in the School of Nursing at
UCSF, and she's the Director
of the Family Nurse Practitioner program.
And through her collaborative work
with community-based organizations
on projects at local,
state, and national levels,
she provides training
throughout the country
on areas of sexual and
reproductive health;
healthy sexuality for people
with special healthcare needs;
adult and adolescent relationship abuse
and reproductive coercion;
consent, confidentiality,
and care of LGBTQ youth.
So Erica, please do come
up here and enlighten us.
(applause)
- Wow, thank you, that
was a very warm welcome.
I'm really delighted
to have an opportunity
to speak with you all today.
This is an issue--I'm an
adolescent and young adult
healthcare provider, so this is an issue
that is quite salient to all the care
that I'm engaged in providing.
But I'm also the mother of
an about-to-turn-20-tomorrow
young woman with Cerebral
Palsy, so I have a real
personal interest in
these issues, as well.
So I'm gonna be talking with you today
about healthy sexuality and adults,
including young adults, with disabilities.
And I have no disclosures.
And I realize you'll see,
if you look at the slides,
there are slides missing
because I'm on of those
just-in-time kind of people, so I realized
just this morning, I was like,
oh, I didn't really define
what I'm talking about with sexuality.
So there are a few extra slides here
you'll see up here that
aren't in your book.
So I'm not gonna read
this definition to you,
I'm gonna give you a
chance to skim over it.
But I want you to look
at the broadness of it.
And I want you to notice that it includes
not just the things that we think about
in terms of sex and sexual
and gender identity and roles,
sexual orientation, but
of intimacy and pleasure.
And these are things that
we often forget about
the needs for in our family members,
and in our patients or
clients with disabilities.
The other thing that I
want you to really notice
is that sexuality is not an act.
Sexuality is not an action.
Sexuality can be totally internal,
it can be an orientation, a
way of looking at the world,
a way of experiencing sensations.
So this isn't all about having sex.
Sexuality is not genitality, but often,
we reduce it to genitality
when we talk about it.
And then we talk about,
what is sexual health?
And again, I want you to notice that these
are the WHO definitions, and
I want you to really notice
that what is required for sexual health.
So a positive and respectful
approach to sexuality
and sexual relationships,
as well as the possibility
of having pleasurable and
safe sexual experiences,
free of coercion,
discrimination, and violence.
And these are issues that
are present for everyone,
and are particularly salient
for people with disabilities.
So when we think about
growth and development,
we often think about it, certainly,
from the pediatric perspective,
it's kind of you're done
with adolescence or maybe young adulthood
if you are aware of brain development
and the issues of brain maturity
maybe not being complete
until the late 20s or even early 30s,
but we think of development
as kind of over.
So development isn't over for anybody
after adolescence and
it certainly isn't over
for people with
developmental disabilities.
So physical development
is generally complete,
what is, is, and what's done is done,
unless someone is going
to make some efforts
to make changes through
the use of hormones
in what their current
physical development is.
But in terms of the rest of development,
brain development, emotional development,
psychosexual, cognitive,
social, ethical, spiritual,
we talk about in my
family that you don't know
if you've hit the wall until
you've been there for a while.
So what's the end point?
Do people with disabilities, people with
intellectual disabilities in particular,
but people with disabilities in general,
who may be more socially isolated,
have fewer social
experiences, what happens
with their social and
emotional development?
And I would posit that you don't know
you've hit the wall until
you've been there for a while,
because when we talk about delays,
what delay means is
that you get there later
and it takes longer, right?
So I wanna encourage you to
always meet with your clients
as people have the potential,
if they have the desire,
to learn and change and develop,
regardless of their age.
And then, is there typical development
for people with disabilities?
Well, first of all,
people with disabilities
is this ginormous conglomeration
of variety of differences, from typical
or neurotypical or normative development.
And so it's very important
that you, like With anybody,
that you really individualize your care,
and yet be aware that there are a series
of developmental tasks that are delayed
for most young adults with disabilities.
These are developmental
tasks you often think of
in the context of adolescence
and young adulthood
that are pushing into young adulthood
and even middle adulthood
in terms of individuating,
separating from family, if that happens,
locus of control shifting,
so there are a lot of things
that happen developmentally in adulthood
for people with disabilities,
depending on their level
of function and the
disability that they have.
There is a wide variety of
cognitive and emotional growth,
and this is more marked
with certain disabilities
than with others.
And just always remember that maturation,
as with children and
adolescents and young adults,
is not just this nice, smooth,
forward-moving process.
It's often two steps
forward, one step back,
sometimes it's one step
forward and two steps back.
But eventually, you see
forward progression.
So there are lots of myths
about people with disabilities
and sexuality, and these are
some of the common myths,
that people with disabilities are asexual,
their sexuality isn't part of their life,
or one of their needs, or
that they're hypersexual,
or that they are solely heterosexual.
Lots of assumptions about sexual behavior
and that sexual behavior
for people with disabilities
is inappropriate behavior.
The assumption around
capacity and consent,
that people with disabilities
do not have the ability
to consent or are incapable of consent.
That people with disabilities only partner
with others with disabilities.
Now that's very unique to the individual,
there actually was pretty recent research
published on people on the autism spectrum
who, the majority of
them, said they preferred
and felt more comfortable in relationships
with other people on the autism spectrum,
or with autism spectrum disorder.
But this is unique to that study
and we don't know how generalizable it is.
The issue of privacy.
We are so ready to invade the privacy
of people with disabilities,
from asking them,
whether they're verbal or not,
whether we may touch them,
whether we can help them
remove some clothing,
whether we can look under
a piece of clothing, or touch
under a piece of clothing,
to not thinking that they should
be able to close their door
at home and not have
anybody come bursting in.
And then the assumption that
people with disabilities
can't or should not be parents.
So what are the facts?
So here are some of the facts.
I have to say, there's
a lot of great websites
for people with disabilities,
mostly from Australia
and Canada, not so much from the U.S.
This House with No Steps has
some really beautiful material
and there's a blog for
people with disabilities,
there's a lot of great material on it.
So this is from their
facts and a few things
that I threw in.
So people with disabilities can be sexual,
can have sex, can enjoy sex.
They don't just have to
have sex with one another.
They are very diverse sexually,
and we'll talk more about that.
Again, newer data about
people on the autism spectrum
shows that there's greater diversity
than with neurotypical populations.
And these are pretty large studies now,
that show much more sexual
and gender diversity
than among the neurotypical population.
And with the right support,
people with disabilities
are capable of having
healthy sexual relationships.
And all people, everyone of
us, every one of our clients,
need the opportunity to learn
and understand about sex
and relationships, and that
means that the teaching
has to be targeted and
in an appropriate way.
And you can't assume that
whatever's happening at school,
which may be nothing for youth
and special education classes
or it may be totally
inappropriate for youth
who have different
learning styles and needs,
don't count on it happening at school.
So one of the big impacts
for people with disabilities
is social isolation,
because really we learn
about relationships from our context.
We learn about relationships
from our families,
from our peers, from
our social interactions,
from the media.
And social isolation and lack
of typical peer experiences
really limits social learning
and is a pretty typical
experience for a young
person with disabilities.
So structuring and
supporting typical adult
social experiences can really
support social learning
for people with disabilities.
Many people need the basics,
again, you can't assume
that the family has had
the level of comfort
or preparation to do this education,
and definitely don't
assume that it's being done
in the school context in
a way that your clients,
patients, or family members
can learn or relate to.
So there's just some basics
around hygiene and self care,
how do you take care of your own body?
They need a lot of help
understanding social relationships
and friends, particularly I said including
in the virtual world, but
I would say particularly
in the virtual world,
because this has been
a great opening,
particularly for young people
with disabilities who
may be pretty isolated,
that they can relate to
others via the Internet,
that they can read blogs,
that they can blog,
that they can go on chat sites, et cetera.
The risk is really when
that virtual relationship
transforms into an actual relationship,
and that's a very risky transition.
And so they need education
and preparation about that.
People with disabilities have higher rates
of exploitation and abuse and
they need appropriate safety
and exploitation prevention education.
They need help understanding
what's a healthy relationship.
Often what we say just in
general adolescent development
is that early adolescent
friend relationships
very much set the tone and predict
romantic relationships
in later adolescence.
Children with disabilities
often do not have
close friendships, they
often do not have wide social
relationships, and so what prepares them
for romantic relationships,
what informs them
about what romantic
relationships should look like,
or what they might even
want in a relationship?
So they need education
about healthy relationships,
and they also need help
identifying what's unhealthy,
what's exploitative, what's
abusive, what's unsafe.
And it's not just good touch, bad touch.
I mean, good touch, bad touch
is a fine place to start
with young children, but it's
not where you should end,
and certainly is not the
most appropriate messaging
for adults who are interested
in intimate relationships.
And then they need
information and education
around sexual health and risk
reduction, like anybody else.
Now, when we talk about people
with disabilities, again,
as I said, we have this huge
group we're talking about,
so what are the issues here
in terms of individuals
with intellectual disabilities?
And these are materials that are from
the Sexuality and You, which
is a governmental website
in Canada, again, an excellent resource.
So, those of you who work with people
with intellectual
disabilities, or even just
learning differences, know
that repetition is important,
it doesn't mean saying the
same thing over and over again.
But it means repeating the
message in different ways,
in different contexts,
with different examples.
And then always checking
back for understanding,
because if we think our
typically developing patients
don't get it, you can
imagine what our a-typically
developing patients might
understand from what we thought
we had communicated to them.
So that teach back is really important.
You need to stay concrete
with your examples.
This takes practice, it's
different than working
with typically-developing individuals.
But many adults with
intellectual disabilities
may not understand abstract concepts,
they may not have developed
abstract thinking.
So the examples you use
need to be concrete,
tangible, specific,
individualized, personal.
And the use of social
stories is a great tool
for many people with disabilities.
Again, something that
we tend to leave behind
when they leave childhood
and adolescence behind,
but can be very useful for adults as well.
So this is an example of concrete examples
of what are your private parts,
and the concepts of private and public.
But for adults, this is even more helpful.
When everybody has a
camera in their pocket now,
including our clients,
you know, the smart phones
are very ubiquitous.
Having pictures of private and public
that relate to their environment,
so if they're in a group living situation,
that's different from
being in a family home.
What's private and public
in a group living situation?
What's private and
public in the community?
Do they have their own room
or do they share a room?
Is their room private?
Does the bathroom door lock?
So, really trying to work with them
and their caregivers to
develop social stories
that really speak to their reality.
So when we use the
picture of the yellow bus,
and we say, this is public.
If they take paratransit,
it is not a yellow bus.
Right?
Can they take that yellow
bus and translate it
to the paratransit, which is not private?
Even if you're alone in the back,
you know, people in
cars think it's private.
Just sit in bridge traffic and you know,
that people in cars think it's private,
but it's not private.
If typically-developing
adults sitting in traffic
don't get it, you can imagine, you know,
if you're sitting in
the back of paratransit,
it might feel private, but it's not.
And if you engage in any
kind of self-pleasuring
in the back of paratransit,
it's gonna be problematic
for you, you're gonna be
kicked off of paratransit,
you're gonna be kicked out of a program.
So, these concepts need
to be very individualized
and specific and I'm a
great fan of social stories,
but I have really become
disenchanted with generic ones.
And I think we really have the ability
to make them specific, and we should.
So you need to go slow,
and this can be hard
because we as providers have
a lot of time pressures.
We bargain for additional
time for our patients
with disabilities, we
get half as much time
as we think we need anyway.
It's often a big deal for them
to come in multiple times,
especially if there's
a mobility disability.
But even with some
behavior issues where maybe
the building is frightening to them,
or the environment, the smells, whatever,
are uncomfortable for your patient,
so you wanna get everything done at once.
But if you just blast
them with information,
you are not really communicating
and they're not gonna get the messages.
So you really do need to go slow
and take it in bite-sized chunks.
Start with the basics,
do not assume they know
their body parts, the
function of their body parts,
how to care for their body
parts, and move on from there.
And appreciate that your
clients are sexual beings
and this can be expressed in many ways.
It doesn't mean that they're
engaging in sexual interactions
with others, but they might.
And that we know that
just talking about sex
doesn't encourage them to try it,
it just helps them be better informed
when and if the moment arises.
So I don't wanna be negative focused,
and I think that the issue
of no is really important.
So clients need to understand
that they have the right to refuse.
We program them, we condition
them to be highly compliant.
There are strangers touching them,
moving their bodies, doing
things to them all the time.
So understanding that they
have the right to refuse,
and understanding how this
fits into their context,
and where their rights might be impaired
is important for them.
Again, using social stories
and social situations
to understand when they
might be in situations
where both volitional
romantic or sexual encounters
might be possible, but also
where abuse might be possible.
The concept of expressing consent.
And there are a few programs
that have been developed
for people with intellectual disabilities,
and there's a new program
for people with autism
that has been--it's not in
the US yet that I'm aware of--
that is sexuality
education that's oriented
toward school-based sexuality education
for people with intellectual disabilities
and people with autism,
two different programs
that are very much tailored to
people with these conditions.
But what does consent mean,
and really getting down
to the nitty-gritty of what consent means.
What do you do, how do
you know when somebody
wants you to kiss them?
How do you let someone know
that you want them to kiss you?
Why is consent important?
Why is consent on the part
of both people important?
Why is it important to verbalize consent,
if it's an individual who can verbalize?
What is respect and what is privacy?
And again, these are very baseline issues
that we really need to invest in educating
and sharing information about.
So, privacy, certainly,
the public and private,
and that sex is private,
self-sexuality is private,
sexual interactions with
other people is private,
and where is your privacy in your world?
And how do you show that
you respect someone?
Why is respect important?
For people with autism spectrum disorder,
sexuality can be impacted by
a number of different things.
Certainly there are behavioral
and information processing
characteristics.
They may have specific sensory
interests or aversions.
They may be hyper or hypo
sensitive towards touching.
They may have preoccupations
or compulsions
and specific rituals.
And so really understanding your client,
their needs, their
interests, their aversions,
and then again, working with them
in their reality, in their context.
Not something that really lends itself
to primary care, I have to say.
It's time intensive, it takes
really time getting to know
your client, they need to feel comfortable
talking about these issues,
so often these kinds of issues
are better addressed in an environment
where they have more
time, where they have time
to develop a relationship,
where it's recurrent visits,
so maybe in a therapy environment.
Sometimes in a case
management environment,
but often not in a
primary care environment.
With social and communicative impairments,
this has a huge impact
on social relationships
and friendships, so right
there you have this decrease
in social learning and context.
Anything that impacts on the development
of friendships impacts on the development
of romantic relationships as well.
They have less opportunity
to learn about sexuality
from their peers.
It influences ones
judgment to apply sexuality
in a socially acceptable
way, or in interpreting
the sexual intentions of others.
So how do you read your environment,
and how do you read
the messages of others?
And it can result in literal
or incorrect interpretations
of information related to sexuality.
So often we try to make,
particularly for individuals
with intellectual disabilities
who may have social or
communicative impairments, we
try to make it really basic.
It can get so basic that
it's not meaningful.
And that it really doesn't give them
the tools or the information
they need around sexuality.
So these issues around sexual codes
and interpreting other's intentions
can be an important issue as well.
And then, this is a study
that was done very recently
on experiences of sex
education and sexual awareness
in young adults with ASD,
and their conclusions
were that young adults
with ASD really did have
specific needs and
requirements that were separate
and different from those
neurotypical young people,
and that high levels of social anxiety
and difficulties in forming social groups
and social bonds with
others really limited
peer interaction, and then that gives you
this whole cascade of impacts
because of that limited
peer and social interaction.
So they don't have as much opportunity
to talk about, joke about, learn about
sex and sexuality from their peers.
They may take things literally
that are not meant literally.
They may misinterpret social cues.
And misinterpretation of social cues
can make you much more vulnerable.
When you can't read someone's intention,
you may misinterpret their attention,
and so it makes you more
vulnerable to abuse.
And then this is another
very recent study,
and again, the language here
is straight out of the study,
so I am not taking
responsibility for the language,
this is how they defined
their population, as adults
with Asperger Syndrome and
high-functioning autism.
Their data was that 73% indicated
that they'd had some romantic
relationship experience,
more women than men.
7% had no desire for any
romantic relationship experience,
which does not mean they're asexual,
it means they're not interested
in a romantic relationship.
That individuals with
Autism Spectrum Disorder
whose partner was also
on the autism spectrum
were significantly more satisfied
with their relationships
than those who had neurotypical partners.
And that the severity of
autism and a range of symptoms
and empathy skills, the
need for social support,
all were not correlated
with relationship status.
So the assumptions we might make
about whether people get
into relationships or not
informed by how we see
their level of function,
is not really predicting their interests
or engagement in romantic relationships.
So, this is from a
meta-analysis, sort of a summary
of the fundings, cause there's
been this kind of big surge
in research around sexuality
and people with autism.
People with ASD, especially women,
showed a higher diversity
in sexual orientation
as compared to the
neurotypical population.
Women with ASD were more
frequently in a relationship
and reported more previous
sexual experiences
than young men or men in general.
Sexual education programs
specifically addressing
the needs of people with autism are scarce
and I have not been able
to find anything in the US.
Again, there is a program
that's been developed
and it's been trialed in Scotland,
with very good results.
There are people here at UC
interested in bringing it here
to work in their autism
program and Langley Porter,
so we'll see what happens with that.
But it is developed to be
a school-based program.
And individuals with ASD show
the whole range of behaviors,
normal-to-problematic sexual behaviors,
just like neurotypical people.
There's nothing particularly
unique in that way.
So as a provider you have to accept
that you may have to go
outside your comfort zone.
I provide services to
adolescents and young adults,
I have for 35 years.
I talk about sex with
my clients all the time.
Many pediatricians do,
many pediatricians don't.
Many adult care providers don't.
So you have to be willing to go there.
You need to be able to
talk about self-pleasuring,
or masturbation, as healthy and normal.
It's a normal outlet for sexual desire
and for sexual energy.
Many experts believe that
inappropriate sexual behaviors
are the result of not having
any appropriate outlets,
so this is why I really
say you have to be willing
to go there and talk about
it and legitimize it.
In my client population, half the kids
think that masturbation gives you acne,
the other half thinks
that it cures your acne.
But, you know, definitely,
they're thinking about it,
they're doing it, we're just
not talking with them about it.
And be aware that people with disabilities
need both permission and
sometimes instruction.
And so it's really important to partner
with their family or support system,
find where is the appropriate
place for instruction,
and appropriate instruction.
Sometimes it's just problem-solving,
like what do you do when you have
a lot of lower-limb
spasticity and any stimulation
on your thigh is gonna
cause you to just clamp up
and to tighten up, and you
know, how can you have sex,
how can you think about positioning,
what's gonna be comfortable for you?
So problem solving.
But to engage in problem-solving,
you have to engage
in a pretty intimate conversation,
I would say a very intimate conversation.
And you have to anticipate
some of the problems
that might come up by thinking about
what is this person's disability,
how does it affect their function,
what is their level of physical function,
how might sexual stimulation
or sexual encounters
with others impact on their
disability and their function?
So in talking about self pleasuring,
first concept is public/private.
You know, where is this
appropriate behavior,
where is this not appropriate behavior.
Normalizing, everybody
does it, this is normal,
this is healthy, and giving permission.
Again, helping people
figure out about positioning
and helping them to
anticipate positioning.
I had a client talk to me
about using a vibrator,
and that she found--this
was a client with CP--
who had intermittent spasticity,
and she said it just
made her really tight.
And so for her it was not
a comfortable experience.
And it's something that
someone had recommended to her,
a peer said, you know,
try it, you might like it,
because she had some issues, you know,
couldn't really do manual stimulation
because of her disability, but for her,
a vibrator, or at least on
the speed she had it set,
just caused her to be really tight.
So these are not conversations
we're used to having
with our clients but
these are conversations
our clients need us to be willing to have.
People with intellectual disabilities
may need help figuring
out appropriate contexts,
so again, that issue of context
and individualizing context.
And everyone needs privacy.
And I'm here to acknowledge
that as a parent,
I'm so used to bursting
into my 20 year-old's room.
It has taken me so much work, which,
with my typically-developing older child,
I never would have dreamed
of bursting into his room,
probably after the age of
12 or 13 without knocking,
and I'm an adolescent health provider.
But here I'll go walking
into my daughter's room
at any time of the day or
night without knocking first.
So we as parents forget,
we as providers forget,
but our clients, our
children, our family members
need us to remember that
they are full human beings,
they are adults, and
they need their privacy.
Remember that some of your clients
are gonna remain concrete,
so they're present oriented,
their experience, their
friend's experience
is what counts for them.
They have pretty limited ability
to project into the future,
they're not generally
realistic in their projections,
and they really can't make that connection
between the long-range outcomes
of their current behaviors.
So risk reduction is very challenging
to both teach to a person
who's a concrete thinker,
and to motivate them to engage in,
because they're in the moment.
Whereas abstract thinkers,
this is what we can use,
typical health education interventions,
they can envision alternatives,
they can evaluate them,
they can take other people's perspectives,
they can reason about
chance and probability.
This is all health education.
Risk reduction is based on these concepts
and yet we have many clients
who don't have the capacity
to really understand these concepts.
So, what does this have
to do with sexuality?
Well, negotiating relationships
is a learned skill
and people with disabilities
have fewer opportunities
to practice it through friendships.
Fewer social outlets, higher
levels of adult supervision,
they desire romantic relationships
but they often don't have
models among their peers.
And sexual decision making
requires abstract thinking.
Parents and care givers and providers
have many concerns, our
concerns are legitimate.
Concerns of abuse and victimization
is a legitimate concern.
Concerns about partner
choice, concerns about dating.
For parents, that concern about
really being able to let go,
and will their adult child be safe?
And concerns about their adult
child's desires to parent,
and I have to say that
healthcare providers
also kind of buy-in to this idea
that people with disabilities
can't or should not parent.
So, we can't talk about
sexuality, unfortunately,
without talking about abuse
because it is a very real issue
for people with disabilities.
There's greater vulnerability
with greater dependency
on others and with communication
limitation difficulties.
With mild impairments,
victimization can sometimes
be due to that desire to fit in,
I wanna be like everybody
else, I may misread
the situation but everybody's doing it,
I wanna do it, too.
Abuse does occur more frequently
with family and caregivers.
Only 14% of reported abuse
is what we would call
stranger abuse, the
rest of abuse is family
and caregiver abuse among
people with disabilities.
And the American Academy
of Pediatrics data
is that there's--look at this range--
two to 10 times, this is
because of reporting biases,
we really don't know, and it varies
in different populations,
but significantly
to extremely significantly, more prevalent
than the general population
without disabilities,
in terms of abuse.
And 68 to 83% of women with
developmental disabilities
will be sexually assaulted
at some time in their life.
So we can't talk about
this without talking about
abuse and the concerns related to abuse.
So, why are people with
disabilities more vulnerable?
What influences these statistics?
People with disabilities are less able
to defend themselves,
they're often not alert
to what is a dangerous situation.
Maybe they don't have that gut feeling,
or they haven't been taught
to trust that gut feeling,
and again, this
misinterpretation of signals
and messages from others.
They don't know to report abuse,
and when they report abuse
they are not listened to,
they are not believed,
they are not acknowledged,
and they are not taken care of.
People with mild intellectual disabilities
may be more vulnerable, again,
because of this desire to
fit in with their peers.
People with disabilities are exposed
to a huge number of caregivers who engage
in intimate care, whether
that's their paraprofessional
in elementary school who
might be wiping their bottom,
to as adults, people are
helping them with dressing,
with positioning, with
toileting, with transportation,
etcetera, so the opportunities
for inappropriate touch
and for abuse are myriad.
And, people with disabilities are taught
from a very early age to be compliant,
to follow directions,
to do what they're told,
to let the person who's doing
what they don't want done,
do it, right?
I mean, my daughter's been
in physical and occupational
therapy since 10 months old.
She's had people pulling on her legs
and trying to get her to spread her legs,
and you know, I mean all these things
that she has the intellectual capacity
to know the difference in.
In fact, at age seven,
it wasn't the best way
to handle it, but she had a new provider,
she was in one of these clinics
where there was, like, 10
providers walk in the room,
and somebody walked up, a male provider,
and started to pull down her pants,
and she slapped him.
(applause, laughter)
So, my, don't slap the
doctor, but I'm proud of you,
you did good, that's right.
And she said, he didn't ask.
And I was like, right, he didn't ask.
So, we can counteract that compliance,
but we have to be aware that
there is that compliance.
So I took a few quotes,
I tried really hard
to put in the audio, how many of you
listen to the NPR series
on abuse and disability.
If you have not listened to it,
there's a podcast, you can Google it,
you can search it on the NPR website,
and I found it really excellent.
And the best thing about it
was that there were so many
voices of people with disabilities.
And so my very limited technical skills
prevent me from sharing
the literal voices,
but I wanna share the stories.
So this is from a series that was called
In Their Own Words, and
this was a gentleman,
older adult, Thomas Mangrum,
who lives in Washington, D.C.,
and he said, We are
taught to trust grown ups
more than anyone else would be,
because when you have a disability,
people are always telling
you, do as that person says,
do as this person says,
and all this other stuff.
Or as Cindy Whitaker
in Austin, Texas, said,
it happens to people like
us--she's talking about abuse--
and why is because we're easy
targets to take advantage of,
we think that the people we're
around, you can trust them,
but you don't know that by looking at 'em.
You just can't judge a
person by their looks.
Or as Debbie Robinson
from Philadelphia said,
I was thinking maybe it
was just a relationship,
a bad one--she's talking
about sexual assault,
she was raped--so I
was thinking that maybe
it was just a relationship, a bad one,
I was just in denial.
I had to figure out
that it's not my fault,
I had to go through all
the memories and name it,
and open up that box you
really don't wanna open up.
Pandora's box.
And Debbie Robinson has
actually become an advocate
working against sexual
assault in vulnerability.
The other things that
were really impactful
about this series were
stories about the response
of the legal system, from law enforcement,
but particularly the legal system,
where, you know, you're
not a good witness,
your story isn't believable,
you don't know the difference.
So all of these things
really impair reporting
and retraumatize an
individual who's already
been traumatized because
the process of reporting,
and trying to get any legal response
is traumatic, as well.
So some warning signs for children,
family members, clients,
particularly those
who have limited verbal abilities
or ability to communicate verbally.
So these are things just to watch for.
And it's not that one plus one equals two
and every time you see these behaviors
it means there's been abuse.
And, abuse should be
in your differentials,
it should be on your radar,
you should be thinking about it
when a client, for example,
refuses to go with people,
or to places that previously
they were fine going to.
So I had a client who was
going to a local program,
had been going there
for a number of years,
was very happy there, suddenly
started crying and moaning
when the bus arrived to
take her to the program.
And then started biting
herself, she had had
some self-injurious behaviors
when she was a younger child,
started engaging in those behaviors again,
she was not verbal.
And she had a great parent
who was really willing
to investigate and talk about this,
and on my encouragement
went, and tried to figure out
what had changed at the program,
and what had changed was
a staff and a supervisor.
So there was new staff and
there was less supervision,
and it was actually there was staff
who was abusing her in her program.
So these things happen,
we need to be aware
and alert to them.
And when you see these
kinds of behavior changes,
anxiety, frustration, and
self-injurious behaviors,
and increase in sexualized
behaviors like masturbation,
just as you would with children.
These can be signs of sexual abuse
and you need to be alert to it.
Obviously, any distress,
they could be feeling unwell,
they could be having a toothache,
they could have a bladder infection,
you know, there could be
a lot of things going on.
But you need to keep
abuse in your differential
and think about it.
So, moving away from abuse
and back to relationships.
Where does capacity fit in?
So I just wanna remind you that legally,
the bar is very low.
In the state of California, any individual
seeking care for pregnancy
related services,
so that's pregnancy prevention,
pregnancy management,
pregnancy termination of any age,
can consent to their own care.
And yet we tell a person with
an intellectual disability,
we think they can't consent.
Right?
So, the bar is not high.
But the individual needs
to be able to say no
or express no and they
also need to be able
to hear no and respond
appropriately to no.
So, you know, again, as there
are many risks for abuse,
there is also many risks for
being labeled a perpetrator
when you're a person with disabilities,
particularly a man with disabilities
who may, for example, engage
in self-sexual stimulation
in a public rather than
private environment.
You know, a mistake that people make.
They can learn not to make that mistake,
but they get labeled.
So you need to be able to say no,
you need to be able to hear no.
You need to understand those basic things
about what happens, what
are the adverse outcomes
if you have sex with another person
in terms of pregnancy and STI risk.
You need to be able to
differentiate appropriate
and inappropriate places.
You need to be able to recognize
persons or situations
that might be a threat.
So, this is--I know you can't read this--
but I wanted you to know that this exists.
So, how many of you have ever tried
to assess capacity in a client?
Do you have tools, objective tools,
to assess capacity?
They just aren't.
So this is, again, I think
this one's from Canada,
yeah, this is Canadian.
It is not perfect and it gives
you some kind of guidance
for informed voluntary consent checklist
and sample questions, so some way
to really assess capacity
and it even gives you--
so you have these questions
that you can ask and answer,
and then it gives you
some guide of capable,
not capable, or unsure.
So it gives you some place to start at
to think about whether this individual
really has the capacity to consent.
So it's a nice tool.
But, again, I think we really need
to think about whether we're
even thinking about this
or going there, I don't
know, you can probably read
this cartoon, the punchline being,
you're only 28, you still
have plenty of time, okay?
So as family members, we
often really don't feel like
our adult children with
disabilities are actually adults,
we don't treat them as actual adults,
and we always have other priorities
besides their sexual lives, right?
So, discrimination can
begin in the family.
But support can also begin in the family.
So all of those skills
that we teach parents,
particularly parents of children
with intellectual disabilities
or cognitive disabilities
around scaffolding, we can
use those same skill sets,
social stories and scaffolding,
to teach about dating, to
teach about relationships.
You know, provide lots
of support and gradually,
in appropriate ways, withdraw support.
And so, the first time,
you might go to the movies
and sit with the couple.
And the next time you
might go to the movies
and sit in the same
movie but not with them.
And the third time it might
be in the same multiplex
but you're going to a different movie.
And eventually, you might get to the point
that they can go on the bus
or paratransit or whatever
and go to the movies by themselves.
So those scaffolding
principles that we use
for teaching so many
skills are very appropriate
for dating skills, as well.
The Internet and social
media really can be
a fantastic tool to safely
explore relationships.
It requires the same skills
as face-to-face interactions,
but you have more time.
You can write something,
look at it and go,
oh that sounds kinda weird, and
erase it and write it again.
I watch this process with
my daughter all the time.
She'll write it and then she'll look at it
and she'll ask me to read it, she'll go,
does that sound weird?
I'm like, ahhh, she goes,
I think it sounds weird.
So, you know, that real life one-to-one,
it's hard to reboot over and over,
but exploring the virtual
world can actually
be a great opportunity.
It requires support and
supervision and involvement
of a parent or caregiver or
coach or therapist or whoever.
And gradual letting go, as
with all of these skills.
And it's, again, as I
mentioned, that transition
from the virtual to the
actual world is where risk is.
So then, click into those
issues around scaffolding,
you could use really concrete ways.
I had one mom tell me that
she actually--cause she had
a 30-something year old, I can't remember,
with an intellectual disability,
who was very interested
in relationships and was
meeting all these people on
the Internet and wanting
to meet them in real life,
and this mom finally,
her mom kept telling her,
it could be anybody, you
don't know who they are,
you don't know if they're
who they saying they are,
and so finally her mom
signed on with a fake ID,
identification, a fake picture,
engaged in a conversation
with her daughter, and then came and said,
you were talking to me, okay.
So you can't get more concrete than that.
I thought it was a pretty creative way
of trying to impress
upon her daughter that--
she said, I was very careful
to not let it go too far,
so it was just the
getting to know you phase.
But she said, you know, you thought
you were getting to
know this guy your age,
and you were actually getting to know me,
pretending to be a guy your age.
So if I can do that, anybody can do that.
So, I wanna close by
talking about pleasure,
because I think this is
really the missing ingredient
and when we have these kinds of talks,
pleasure kind of gets refined out of them.
And this is a quote from The
Missing Discourse of Pleasure,
from the year 2000, and this
is Michael Tepper, who says,
access to pleasure is the
real accessibility issue.
Full inclusion means access to pleasure.
It means a reasonable
chance for relationships.
And, I don't know how many of you
are familiar with Sins Invalid,
but this is a group
that, they have a film,
they have performances, they do education,
and they really focus on
people with disabilities
and relationships and sexuality.
And they're pretty out
there, pretty blunt,
pretty in your face, and
they do beautiful work.
So this is just a screenshot
from their website.
And I'll close with
our more typical images
of happy couples.
So thank you for your time and attention.
(applause)